on your screen is Francis Morel up a 30
years ago at the age of 26 she wrote a
book called diet for a small planet
which changed a generations thinking
some people in the generations thinking
about hunger around the world she is
back with a new book called hopes edge
the next diet for a small planet and
your message in this book is what that
there is more than enough food in the
world to feed us all and that really the
question that I asked with my daughter
in this new book is why is it that we
are creating a world that none of us
really want because I really think most
people all people want everyone to be
able to have food that they need and so
we travel on five continents asking
where our lessons emerging for how to
create societies in which we all can eat
and certainly it's not a lack of food
there's more than enough to make us all
chubby in the world this in the in the
three decades since you first wrote
about this in this country alone where
have the trends been going and the
issues that you raised well if the trend
is now going global where we have this
incredible paradox where we have the
existence of the underfed at the same
time we have growing numbers of overfed
and so that right after our book came
out the Surgeon General came out with
report saying that obesity is a huge
public health problem in this country
and that it is causing almost as many
deaths related to diseases from
overeating as are caused by tobacco so I
think that what is emerged in the last
30 years is this intensified paradox
where you have the underfed both here in
this country where we now have you know
millions of people relying on charity
for food and not knowing where the next
meal is coming from at the same time we
have this problem of obesity because our
diet is increasingly meat centered
highly processed highly fatty sugar diet
so that's what we try to cut through and
hopes edge and show people that there is
another path we'd like to open up our
phone lines so you can talk to Frances
Marla pay our phone numbers are on the
screen right below me you can see that
they're divided by party affiliation as
we often do here do you consider the
issue
that you're interested in partisan in US
political terms none at all not at all
they're so fundamental and that's why
when I was 26 I started with food what
could be more fundamental for the
species then what what's up with us you
know the first thing that every species
does is feed itself and its offspring
and we haven't achieved that on a
planetary basis we're still struggling
to do that so I think it crosses every
political spectrum every orientation
absolutely as a for instance would you
tell our audience about how you approach
food personally what I need well it's
I've been eating pretty much the same
thing for the last 30-some odd years and
that is that once I learned that we that
actually a meat centered diet was not
the healthiest diet and what is the
healthiest diet is a one that is
centered in the plant world and is also
the best for the earth this was the
great discovery I made in my 20s so my
diet is plant centered diet I I haven't
eaten meat in 30-something years and a
range of of in all of that world where
there's so much variety I think growing
up as I did in Fort Worth Texas where
you know in cow town I thought that that
you know dinner was steak and potato
actually not steak and with me lovin and
potatoes but I discovered the world of
foods and vegetables and nuts and seeds
and all of this great variety so that's
where my diet is and how does your
personal choices about food then writ
large affect hunger can you kind of take
us down the food my my wake-up call as a
26 year old I guess was the discovery
that in this country we feed 16 pounds
of grain and soy to produce one pound of
meat and I said wait a minute you know
the experts are saying we're running out
of food but we're actually creating the
scarcity by funneling so many resources
into the creation of meat and the reason
we're doing that is because hungry
people here and throughout the world
don't have the economic wherewithal to
make a demand on that acreage to grow
food to eat directly and so what I saw
then this grain-fed meat centered diet
is really a symptom of a particular kind
of market system that concentrates
wealth in the hand
whew so the wonderful thing about
choosing a plant center diet is that
it's doing best what's best for my body
because now we know we didn't know 30
years ago but we do now that a meat
centered diet also contributes to heart
disease and cancer and hypertension and
these problems and so when doing what's
best for my body is also placing a
lighter weight on the planet in terms of
our resources
everything from soil erosion to water
consumption which is another major issue
with meat production I learned Anna and
I for this book that it takes it can
take as much as 10,000 gallons of water
to produce one pound steak so that's
another huge issue in our world today
Anna is Anna
lepay your your daughter's you know in
the way of many children did she ever
rebel against the lifestyle which you
brought her up well not really I mean
she's been asked that question booth
we've been touring together and she says
well my mom really let me decide and
that made me very happy and so she chose
some time in her mid-teens to also
become you know thin her diet in the
plant world and she's very very healthy
he's got let's take some calls for you
first is Silver Spring Maryland welcome
to the Washington journal you're on the
air I my question or comment is was
really going to be a question a comment
for the other guy that was previously on
but you know I think it really is the
same problem the problem with world
hunger seems to jump from a greater
problem with world resource management
I'm calling from Silver Spring really
from my car phone as I'm driving to work
in a single passenger vehicle the need
for public transportation for me if was
if it was effectively phased in over the
next 20 years by this government or the
next government could effectively stave
off other resource management problems
that our country seems to have we've got
a big demand for meat we've got a big
demand for trucks to carry than me and
then we've got a big demand for trucks
to have highways basic to carry the meat
or the oil I think it's just the choice
of the kinds of resources that our
country seems to be depended on that
deals all of this from the you know the
deforestation in Brazil that you know
basically supplies the meat market here
for McDonald's to you know what have you
it's beets still seems to stem from what
I think the lady is saying an overrun
market based economy that is only there
for short-term profit thank you sir well
I do agree that there is a link and and
I think the caller hit on it right at
the end there were in our in our work we
point out that that the the problem is
that we see ourselves increasingly
simply as these selfish accumulators in
a market and not co-creators of a public
policy he referred to in terms of
transportation but one could say the
same things in terms of food and so for
example one of our on her journey as we
traveled on five continents we went to a
city in Brazil the fourth largest city
in Brazil that has declared food a right
of citizenship good healthy food a right
of citizenship so it wasn't then the the
outcome of that wasn't to do away with
the market but in a sense to put us in
the driver's seat we as citizens
creating the communities we want and
then to make the market a servant of
that goal so it's really I think the
link between the earlier show and and
our topic is this how do we see
ourselves do we see ourselves simply as
having to bow down before the market and
just live with whatever the market
outcome is because we're incapable of
nothing better or are we creatures
social creatures who can create
communities create public policies like
the right to healthy food so that we can
live in communities that work for all of
us and I think it goes that deep if this
is a list of books that Frances Moore
lepay has authored including works on
world hunger and on aid is obstacle 20
questions about foreign aid in the
hungry who funds your work well right
now it is
by my own wits if you will my own riding
but most of my life I have been in the
nonprofit world I co-founded two
nonprofit organizations the Institute
for food and development policy of food
first in Oakland California in its 28th
year and so for much of my life I was
riding as a staff person of that
organization and then the Center for
living democracy which lasted for ten
years and so during that period my work
was funded by that organization next
call for use from Binghamton New York
you're on the air
hello thank you for c-span couple
comments couple questions you stated
that production is not the problem it is
the transportation of the food to the
places that need it since production is
not the problem how can we apply that
argument to genetically modified foods
why do we need these genetically
modified foods if we have enough food
it's just getting there that's the
problem well I agree that we do not need
genetically modified organisms that this
is just as when I began thirty years ago
we were told that we needed massive in
inputs of chemicals we needed massive
amounts of pesticides and fertilizers to
grow the food we need today we're told
that we need genetically modified
organisms and neither is true the
problem is that people do not have
access to the food that is being
produced so the question is access and
what gives people access well having
land to grow food for oneself certainly
is one way to have access and having
income in which to buy the food that we
need and so for example part of our book
talks about movement that is growing now
worldwide called the fair trade movement
which ensures that those people who grow
food are getting a return on it that
allows them to to keep their land and by
the additional food they need to survive
so so I think this question of access
why do people throughout the world not
have access to the food that's already
being produced so that we have this
illusion of cheap grain that then gets
fun to look funnel into livestock these
are the questions we need to be asking
not how do we produce genetically
modified organisms with all the risks
involved Annapolis Maryland good morning
good morning Thank You c-span what a
wonderful sight it is to see Francis
Moore lepay and I must say what you're
eating obviously agrees with you because
I'm sure you look a lot younger than you
are so I just want to thank you very
much for your work and I just want to
mention a remarkable event that happened
in 1977 that many people know about
which was the generation of something
called a hunger project and the purpose
of the Hunger Project was and hunger
within 20 years which obviously didn't
happen because we're well past 1997
however it was really technically to
create the context in which the end of
hunger would be an idea whose time has
come which it I would say royally
succeeded at and there's one of its
founders I'm immensely proud of the fact
that that's happening and you're showing
up and all the work you've done has
demonstrated a great example of that so
I was wondering if you would share
anything that you know about the hunger
project and what it's done just as a
tribute and keep going yes thank you
there are many wonderful anti-hunger
organizations now Hunger Project is one
of these organizations food first I
mentioned is another Oxfam America there
are there are so many organizations now
working to help people understand that
the problem is not in adequate
production the problem is how do people
have access to the land and food that
they need to feed themselves and so
that's really why we we wanted to show
all the sense of the scent of the
possible rather than the impossible
would you give statistics on hunger in
the United States in 2002 well there are
all sorts of estimates but I do know
that there are 20 more than 20 million
people who are dependent on charity for
food and I think that is a huge measure
of the lack of you know if you have to
turn to charity if you have to turn to
food banks and soup kitchens certainly
you are at in danger of being hungry how
about globally well globally estimates
are somewhere
near a billion people globally again
it's very hard to pin down the numbers
we do know that a close to half of the
world is living on less than $2 a day so
again people are at the edge of how can
you meet your basic needs with that kind
of severity in the world Berkeley
California good morning I really admire
your work and mm see you as living proof
of the veracity of your message and
would ask for suggestions as to how your
principles and concepts could be
introduced into educational curricula as
well as the marketing strategies of
corporate America and that they get a
broader perspective as to the impact of
their activities as far as health
problems health risks are thank you so
much for that question actually our book
begins in a school it begins in an
edible school yard in Berkeley
California and Martin Luther King's
school where children have actually
designed created their own garden from
which they are in which they are
planting and harvesting and then
preparing and serving the food to one
another and learning science at the same
time so this movement of children
actually reconnecting with the earth so
that they don't think that food grows on
aisle three somewhere that this is I
think a very important innovation in
education that can help children break
through what we call the thought traps
the idea that we simply have to leave
food to an impersonal type of market
force that concentrates wealth and cuts
people out of access to good food so
this sort of curriculum innovation I
think is central and in California
actually the goal is to have a garden in
every school in the state your buyers of
your book will not only learn about
policy and about success stories but you
also have recipes for example here is a
recipe from the Edible Schoolyard
what was your thinking and combining all
these different ways of telling the
story well we wanted to show by having
actually we have a hundred
pages of wonderful recipes from leading
vegetarian and Whole Foods chefs from
all around the country including Molly
Katzen and people like this have been at
the forefront of this movement to show
how in the last thirty years this notion
that we can Center our diets in the
plant world we can buy from local
producers so that we're not dependent on
transportation of food over long
distances that we can grow from
sustainable organic farmers near us that
we wanted to highlight that by actually
showing people in recipes that they can
cook in their own kitchens and we also
for example highlight the movement
communities for into agriculture so that
people actually can have a face-to-face
relationship with their farmer and they
know where their food is coming from I
think this is more and more important to
people for Francis Moore lepay let's
hear next from Peoria Illinois welcome
good morning from the little bit that
I've heard so far I think I probably
agree with the points that you've made
I've got one comment or question and
that is when you mentioned I believe 16
pounds of grain to raise a to produce a
pound of steak or pot of beef I've heard
that figure before and I thought it
sounded like a like a horrible thing to
happen and then somebody from the
Cattlemen's Association wrote in and
said hey that's what happens in the feed
Lots but in order to get those cows
grown big enough to get into the feed
Lots we turn them loose on land that
can't produce anything else and they
waltz around eating that little bit of
grass that they've got and grow into
seven or eight hundred pound animals
that then they then finish off with with
the corn and I think to maintain your
credibility you don't want to give the
impression that the cows are raised from
the time they're little bitty calves on
nothing but grain they really do end up
being a manufacturing process that turns
that that stinking poxy grass into some
pretty tasty beef which I which I agree
is not the healthiest thing to eat
thanks a lot
absolutely yes throughout all of history
human beings have
used ruminants like cattle to produce
high-grade protein out of grass but what
we have done is by adding in this heavy
feedlot experience for the cattle we
have turned cattle into protein disposal
systems if you will so yes I include all
of that information that you just
articulated in diet for a small planet
and describe it all in the footnotes and
but nonetheless that is unfortunate case
today that we that protein that we've
turned livestock into protein disposal
systems College Station Texas hi good
morning I have a comment ad especially
to the last caller he was talking about
the future meat ratio I'm affiliated
with the poultry industry and currently
the feed conversion ratio of chicken is
about 1.1 or 1.2 pounds of feed to one
pound of meat and this is significantly
less than a 16-point to one pound ratio
you quoted I just wanted to make that
comment thank you
yes poultry are more efficient but
they're in additional problems of course
when we are talking about factory
farming there are enormous problems of
pollution water pollution which is a
huge huge issue so it doesn't end the
the problems of factory farming of heavy
intensive industrial style farming don't
in simply with the conversion ratio into
question about five minutes left next
Madison New Hampshire yes I just wanted
to say I love you thank God for you
bless your work and and bless your
daughter the factory farming issue that
you just mentioned treating live animals
that have blood running through their
bodies that have heartbeats that feel
pain and suffer just as we do I think is
a huge issue that our culture that our
society must deal with but my question
is how can we enlist the help of the
venture capitalists and the media to
help educate people number one about the
problems with animal agriculture and
number two how can we enlist the help of
venture capitalists and the media to
help teach at least children that a
plant be
is maybe is is the future for saving
their environment making them much much
healthier and in making the world a much
much safer place because that that way
we will deal with the hunger issues that
are I think a lot of terrorism stem from
and God bless you again and keep you
well thank you thank you it's very kind
of you I think so important for the
media is to help us see that there is
now emerging more and more evidence more
and more practitioners of an approach to
farming and eating that is best for our
earth best for ourselves in other words
when we were finishing our book there
was a new study out showing that
globally sustainable agricultural
practices that is those that issue
chemicals and work with nature in a
process called agro ecology that this is
highly productive I think to break
through the myth that we need to rely on
industrial style farming that we need to
have all of the pesticides and chemicals
that this is you know this is part of
what we must break through that myth by
showing as we do in Hope sedge examples
of farms that are benefiting directly by
working with the earth and not using
chemicals and I think another piece of
this is working with children in the
classroom through the school garden
movement and getting to know our farmers
directly through the community supported
agriculture movement let me have you
respond to one of your critics his name
is Dennis Avery writing for the Knight
Ridder papers he says that her your
recent assertion that people should get
their essential nutrients from kitchen
gardens instead of buying food from big
companies alipay is apparently one of
the millions of people who have
forgotten what it was like when
America's foods lacked key essential
ingredients here are a few facts to jog
their memories and he has two pages of
examples such as fortified milk which
helps prevent rickets and iodized salt
which has gotten rid of
more mental disabilities and deforming
goiters and the like and other examples
such as that what would you say - well I
think the premise that that somehow
we're advocating everybody just get
their food from kitchen garden so
certainly we're I think that that's not
the focus of our work but I think that
in fact the direction of our of our work
this idea of working with nature to
rebuild the soil what what is clear is
that our soil is being depleted and
therefore the nutrients that we can get
from it are are being depleted so that
the direction that we're advocating is
really working with nature to rebuild
our soil so that it does provide us with
the nutrients that we all need to thrive
and so this is this plant centered diet
head that that our book talks about that
is emerging as the healthy diet
throughout the world it really takes
into account these considerations
Geneseo Illinois a very very quick
question yes one question I have is what
has been the mass effect of the band of
DDT since the 1960's in the amount of
people that have died from malaria